le journalisme dominant a perdu une
grande partie de son autonomie
professionnelle qui consiste normalement
à travailler sans se demander si ça va
alimenter la thèse du complot ou au
contraire si il faut suivre les ordres
donnés par le gouvernement ou le courant
dominant ou ce que pense la majorité des
gens qui pensent bien ou mal etc on a la
une un miroir grossissant de cette perte
de cultures professionnelles qui
normalement implique que les
journalistes fassent des enquêtes
prennent du recul prennent du temps sans
se laisser dicter leur calendrier la une
de leurs journaux par par la peur de
déplaire à x ou de déplaire à y ou de
s'embarquer dans des thèses qui sont ou
non un complotiste et on a depuis le
début de cette pandémie
un traitement qui est
qui est souvent extrêmement
superficielle qui rebondit sur la
dernière anecdote et qui cherche le
spectaculaire dans la polémique dans les
polémiques qui a depuis le début sur le
traitement ou pas sûr sur didier rahout
sur l'origine du du virus
on favorise finalement des pugilats de
l'expression caricaturale de position
notamment les chaînes d'information en
continu qui doivent animer avec du bruit
avec du spectaculaire sans arrêt et tout
ça ne favorise pas l'idée bah tiens si
j'essayais de faire une enquête si je
m'interrogeais sur les logiques de
systèmes qui rendent ou non plausibles
le ce virus sont d'origine naturelle ou
pas et du et par conséquent on accroît
on accroît l'opacité on accroît le
complotisme parce que les gens ont perdu
confiance dans les médias et c'est ça
qui est extrêmement dangereux parce que
on n'arrive plus finalement avoir un
débat un peu sérieux sur quoi que ce
soit par peur de s'y perdre sa part
d'autres choses et c'est cette sérénité
qu'il faut retrouver
[Musique]